et avec nous Patrick Pelot bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous président de
l'Association des médecins gentils de
France et Frédéric Valtou bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes débutant de
Seine-et-Marne ancien président de la
Fédération hospitalière de France
Mathias nous a rejoint on va parler avec
vous de l'hôpital est-il prêt à faire
face à l'été vous nous direz ce que vous
en pensez et plus largement comment
lutter contre les déserts médicaux vous
avez porté une proposition va-t-elle
assez loin faut-il revoir la liberté
d'installation des médecins et appliquez
des contraintes vous nous direz ce que
vous en pensez mais d'abord bien sûr on
va voir l'actualité dans nos régions et
on parle des suites du drame de Nanterre
et des tensions qui ont eu lieu cette
nuit dans plusieurs villes de France
[Musique]
et on va aller à Versailles dans les
Yvelines retrouvez Michel semando merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
directeur de 78 actu on va évidemment
parler avec vous des tensions des
affrontements qui ont suivi la mort de
Naël qui a été tué par un policier après
un présumé refus d'obtempérer votre
département a été le théâtre de
plusieurs affrontements quelle est la
situation Michel semando aujourd'hui
[Musique]
merci Michel c'est mondo merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous pour nous parler
de cette actualité et détention qui ont
lieu dans les Yvelines mais également
dans plusieurs villes de France Frédéric
valthoux vous êtes député horizon à la
majorité présidentielle on le rappelle
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet du climat
actuel du pays est-ce que vous redoutez
que ça dégénère encore plus
que ça les génère encore plus je
souhaite pas et mais on voit bien que la
situation elle est
incandescente elle est difficile elle
est tendue on a déjà vécu ce type
d'enchaînement par le passé et on se
rappelle des émeutes de 2005 et depuis
il y a eu d'autres d'autres moments de
fortes tension on voit bien en quoi
aujourd'hui on a besoin dans des bas
publics d'apaisement on a besoin que la
justice fasse son travail à la fois
tranquillement sereinement mais aussi
peut-être qu'elle puisse dire des choses
de manière claire transparente assez
rapidement maintenant la justice prendra
le temps qui lui est nécessaire mais
voilà il y a besoin de mettre des
éléments peut-être objectifs qui
peut-être permettront si on y ajoute
effectivement des paroles d'apaisement
qu'on évite des émeutes qui aujourd'hui
prennent quelques heures après le doram
prête déjà un tour qui est très mauvais
et quand on crée les paroles
d'apaisement qu'on tenté de prononcer
hier Emmanuel Macron Elizabeth borne
quartier en jetant de lui sur le feu on
le sait et ça je veux dire ça n'est pas
très responsable moi je on l'a vu à
l'assemblée des déclarations à la va
vite pour voilà il y a là il y a une
course à la petite phrase je vois
certains élus et les filles je vois
certains même du rassemblement national
on voit bien que les extrêmes ont à
savoir à bénéficier de ce type de
situation ce qui est une erreur terrible
Patrick
de nos quartiers quand on voit ce qui
s'est passé cette nuit dans plusieurs
villes de France
oui on est au début de quelque chose je
tiens l'attaque ne serait-ce que de la
prison de Fresnes cette nuit c'est une
première qui avait pas eu en 2005 c'est
je pense qu'on en fait là vous avez un
effondrement de quelque chose
probablement d'une sorte de pacte social
qui est devenu invivable pour la
population vous avez vous avez
il y a ce jeune homme qui a été tué
c'est absolument dramatique mais il y a
aussi
toute cette structuration de la relation
entre la population et la police qui est
totalement brisée et en effet je rejoins
ce que dit Monsieur jeunesse et la
police pour vous c'est entre la
population et la politique et là il y a
une responsabilité politique monstre
mais je pense que en effet va falloir
trouver les ressources politiques très
rapidement pour calmer tout ça mais ça
ne va pas s'arrêter comme ça ça ne va
pas s'arrêter comme ça et
moi je sincèrement je le crains parce
que vous savez si en plus de ça vous
vous êtes assez coincé parce que si vous
faites une défiance de la police la
police va se retirer donc vous allez
avoir encore plus
d'émeutes et de sa cage
et si vous allez trouver vers la
défiance de la population donc là c'est
une situation extrêmement complexe et en
effet la classe politique devrait être
unie pour trouver des solutions
multifactorielles
parce que à mon avis ne vous arrêtez pas
simplement sur le drame je pense qu'il y
a tout un contexte par rapport à ces
quartiers ou notamment tous les services
publics qui ont été abandonnés
est-ce que ça peut être une étincelle
parce qu'on a déjà entendu cette nuit et
des gens dire mais on fait ça pour Noël
mais on fait aussi ça pour les
soulèvements de la terre est-ce que ça
va être finalement un ensemble de choses
qui va enflammer les quartiers on le
sait et on l'a vu à d'autres occasions
qui sont pas forcément des drames
qu'aujourd'hui les colères s'agrègent
les colères sont multiples trouvent
leurs racines effectivement dans un
certain nombre de de de de de de raison
ou de cause qui c'est effectivement
comme le passé chelou qui sont
multifacts factorielle et qui viennent
s'agréger à l'occasion là d'un drame il
y a quelques années pardon mais les
gilets jaunes c'était pas simplement la
colère contre des mesures fiscales sur
l'essence et sur l'énergie c'était
derrière effectivement l'expression de
colle et de de choses beaucoup plus
profondes donc on voit bien qu'un drame
comme celui-là il peut effectivement
être catalyseur d'une colère qui Patrick
le temps politique et le temps du drame
et la réaction au drame sont
parce que si jamais il y a des morts ce
weekend vous n'avez plus le temps
il va falloir trouver des réponses
effectivement qui sont des réponses
immédiates d'apaisement je le redis la
parole politique
il a déjà pris la parole il a trouvé les
mots d'apaisement s'il faut peut-être
qu'il les redisent si je sais qu'il le
redira il aura il sera attentif à ça ça
changera rien Patrick Pelot pour vous
rien du tout là
rien du tout il faut vraiment des actes
forts des actes d'apaisement
dans un temps aussi court tes actes très
difficiles parce que vous savez la
politique de la ville aller dans ces
quartiers nous nous quand on y va avec
les véhicules du Samu vous y allez il y
a plus rien on a abandonné les gens
d'accord on a la défiance par rapport
mais cela si vous voulez alors là c'est
tout un programme politique c'est là où
la politique d'ailleurs redevient un
sens sur l'éducation sur les services
publics de proximité
sur le fait que d'aider les familles
dans ces quartiers pour l'aide à
l'éducation l'aide au quotidien c'est
tout ça vous voyez ce qui est
significatif ils ont ils ont pillé les
magasins de nourriture et des voilà
c'est voyez il y a une pauvreté vraiment
vrai dans tout ça c'est
il y a aussi des attaques cette nuit
contre des bâtiments publics contre des
lieux qui sont plutôt des lieux je veux
dire qui sont là pour essayer de
soutenir la population des médiathèques
des mairies bon donc on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui c'est les symboles mais
on voit bien que le malgré tout le le
temps politique est un temps long enfin
quand le président de la République va à
Marseille c'était ces trois derniers
jours et qui montre effectivement tout
ce qui a pu déjà être accompli depuis un
an mais ça prend du temps
de permettre de desserrer le nombre
d'élèves dans les écoles pour que
retrouver une possibilité d'apprendre
sereinement dans certains quartiers que
l'hôpital Nord de Marseille installation
de consultation parce que et cetera et
du soin dans des quartiers etc
évidemment que ça se fait pas en un
claquement de doigts donc il y a un
travail de reconquête de de
réaffirmation la présence de service
public inévitablement est un travail
long je dis pas qu'il est fait partout
de manière admirable je dis qu'il y a
des choses qui se font né en moi et on
l'a encore vu à Marseille ces derniers
jours mais effectivement le temps du
drame et de la réaction de RAM n'est pas
le temps de la réponse politique et
aujourd'hui il y a une colère qui va
être compliqué à contenir bien sûr non
mais juste pour revenir sur ce que vous
venez de dire sur l'accès aux soins
si vous prenez par exemple l'accès aux
soins
sur le psyché sur la psychiatrie si vous
avez dans ces quartiers c'est
extrêmement difficile je vous soigner si
vous avez une dépression si vous n'allez
pas bien la pédopsychiatrie ça fait vous
étiez président de la FHF ça fait
longtemps d'accord combien depuis
combien d'années on a abandonné la
pédopsychologie la pédopsie
vous avez des sujets gras donc bien sûr
vous allez faire sur l'hôpital Nord une
consultation un accès qui donnera sans
doute des services mais ça sera
nettement insuffisant par rapport à
l'ampleur du truc quand vous avez des
centres médicaux psychologiques puisque
vous savez ces sectoriser un peu partout
en France et que vous entendez ce que
vous raconte les psychiatres c'est
terrible bien sûr on se souvient des
images de cette agression de cette dame
à Bordeaux par un homme qui en fait en
rupture de soi psychiatrique en rupture
de traitement et qui a agressé quelqu'un
qui est maintenant en hôpital
psychiatrique en secteur fermé bon mais
vous vous posez la question pourquoi
finalement avant quand vous aviez il y
avait des moyens qui avaient été donné
sur les centres médico-psychologiques
les malades étaient suivies ah il
venaient pas on allait le chercher on
lui donnait son traitement on avait les
traitements injectables etc tout ça on a
abandonné donc maintenant en effet vous
avez tout cet accès aux soins et quand
d'un coup vous avez des quartiers qui
vont mal le psyché va mal quand on a
abandonné les services publics la poste
les les les centres de protection
materno infantile etc tout ça vous avez
abandonné une population et les gens
sont les gens sont plutôt très patients
et puis là vous avez un facteur
déclenchant un drame absolu d'accord et
voilà maintenant je pense que la
situation je sincèrement je sais je
pense qu'elle est totalement
incontrôlable mais bon
[Musique]